okay this is step four of how to solve
the Rubik's Cube what you should have
now is you should have two bottom
completed layers for the next step what
we want to do is we're going to place a
yellow cross in the top layer now for
the top cross you don't have to worry
about corner pieces you just want to
focus on the edge pieces and the central
piece so what we first need to know is
this algorithm and this is one of the
moves that we need to know in order to
get the final layer done so the move is
front clockwise top clockwise right
clockwise top counter clockwise right
counter clockwise and front counter
clockwise the I stands for inverse okay
so if you look at the diagram I have
this is one of the occasions where you
just have a middle central piece and
there are no other pieces around you
might have a corner piece or two but
like I said you don't pay attention to
the corner pieces so doing this move
once from this position will get you to
a line doing the move from the line will
get you to what I like to call the L and
then doing the move from the L will get
you to the final cross on the top layer
so if we look at the cube that I have
and you just look at these edge pieces
with the central piece you'll see that I
have the line so what I need to do is I
need to do the move twice in order to
get to the cross so if I do the move
while holding the cross you want to hold
the line so that it's horizontal so you
do front clockwise top clockwise right
clockwise top counterclockwise right
counterclockwise
and front
counterclockwise what you now see is
that we have the L it's more like a
backwards L and this is the position
that you want to hold it in so you want
to hold the line horizontal and you want
to hold that L like so so what you do
from this step is you do the same move
and doing the move from this position
will get you to that cross so it's front
clockwise top clockwise right clockwise
top counterclockwise
right counterclockwise and front
counterclockwise what you now see is
that you have a cross and you don't want
to pay attention to this corner piece
just yet unless you have the cross then
the next step we do have to pay
attention to what is on the side here as
far as the yellow pieces are concerned
and also what kind of corner pieces we
have on top next to this yellow cross so
that concludes step four and it should
not be too much of a problem just note
that if you have if you have a single
central piece like so you're going to
have to do the move one two three times
until you get that cross if you have
this piece already you want to make sure
that it's in this orientation and then
this would be your front side here if
this is the top of the cube this is the
top of the cube in all cases and that is
the move you want to memorize or you
want to write down so that you know
exactly what you have to do in order to
get to the cross once you have the cross
you're ready to move on to step 5